jeff zucker runs cnn like a political
campaign there's not much of a market
for him running for office
everyone at cnn has a role just like in
a campaign and the lowest level are the
goons in ice hockey they'd be called
enforcers
obedient thuggish not very bright their
job is to smack the people
jeff sucker tells him to smack one of
these jowly screamers
zucker's personal favorite hosts a
weekend show about the media
every saturday he gives voice to his
boss's weird obsessions in vendettas and
calls it news
the formula never changes except this
weekend it did change
here's author michael wolff was invited
on to say one thing and then midway
through the segment couldn't take it
anymore and decided to tell the truth
watch i think the media has done a
terrible job on this
i think you yourself um you know why
you're a nice guy you know you're full
of sanctimony
um you know you become part of one of
the parts of the problem
of the media you know you come on here
and you and you have a
um you know a monopoly on truth
you know you know exactly how things are
supposed to be done
um you know you are why one of the
reasons people can't stand the media
sorry you're cracking me up
it's your fault it's how so what should
i do differently michael
you know don't talk so much listen more
you know people have genuine problems
with it with
with the media the media doesn't get the
story right
the media exists in its own bubble
um that's true i agree you uh
um you know you gotta stop i mean that
last segment that
that that i just had to listen to of all
the people saying the same old stuff
also you're incredibly repetitive it's
week after week i mean
you're the flip side of of of of donald
trump
um you know fake news and you say
virtuous news
you know i they're they're not they just
figure out what is real i mean
i'm listening well well figuring out
yeah figuring out what is real is not so
is not so uh it's not so easy and and
you know most people don't want to talk
turn to brian stelter to tell us what's
real
i'm sorry
don't talk so much listen more you are
full of sanctimony you're incredibly
repetitive
to which the anchor said it's hard to
imagine more succinct summation of
modern media than that
sanctimonious and stupid exactly
smart people understand their own flaws
self-righteousness
is for morons that's why you see so much
of it on television
that's about it for us tonight don't
forget our conversation with dennis
kucinich is on fox nation
have a wonderful hey sean hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to
fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it
anywhere else